salut cette vidéo c'est la première
d'une nouvelle série que j'avais un
petit peu commencé en fin d'année au
lieu de vous faire un master class au de
vous donner une astuce concrètes pour
savoir faire quelque chose je vais
plutôt essayer de vous l'expliquer en
l'apprenant à quelqu'un comme ça ça me
permet de détecter aussi les difficultés
d'apprentissage et vous même vous voyez
que c'est possible de le faire j'espère
que ça vous motivera pour cette première
vidéo je vais vous apprendre un
calendrier perpétuel c'est à dire qu'à
la fin vous allez être capable de dire
quel jour de la semaine
ton n'importe quelle date de 2017 ou
2018 ou 2019 ou 2020 est gelée sûrement
mis dans le kit donc vous le savez déjà
je veux faire cette vidéo avec amics m
j'enlève ce pull que vous voyez beaucoup
trop souvent en ce moment j'enfile une
veste et c'est parti
[Musique]
donc l'idée maintenant c'est d'apprendre
comment faire un mix m et vous apprenez
en même temps j'avais déjà fait ce type
de vidéos pour vous apprendre déterminer
quel jour de la semaine tomber n'importe
quelle date de l'année j'ai fait ça
l'année dernière 2016 barre des 5 euros
pierre bien bien un marché à deux trois
ou quatre cents vu déjà
ouais c'était au tout début de la chaîne
donc j'essaie de les cheveux c'est ouais
avant que 420 400 bus et là il y avait
1,7 et 1,5 vraiment le coup de le
refaire cette année et en plus comme on
vient passer une année bissextile
on repart sur un cycle de quatre ans
d'accord avec cette méthode là ça permet
de tenir les quatre ans tient pas moins
clair alors que je les retiens que les
régimes logiquement à dire que la lame à
technique à l'époque pour quatre ans il
ya deux choses à apprendre à mick celle
de la chaîne maxime où l' inverse c'est
eux qui décident il ya deux choses qu'il
faut que tu saches faire oui mais après
tu seras capable de le faire
première chose j'ai besoin de vérifier
une partie de ta table de 7,7 fois un
set 7 x 2 14 3 x 7 21,4 soit 7,8 est
vraie elle veut tu vois je sentais que
tu galères et après eh bien c'est
d'ailleurs là c'est là là on était en
mode calcul
ouais cette fois 7 49 parce que menez
loire et la patrie la deuxième étape
j'ai un code à te faire apprendre oui ce
code là on va le créer en prenant tous
les premiers lundis de chaque mois de
l'année d'accord mais 2010 est vacant
par exemple le premier lundi du mois de
janvier nous tomber le 1 d'accord donc
notre code il va commencer par fin
d'accord vous avez pas forcément besoin
de leur dire dès le départ vous pouvez
marquer quelque part la voir en vidéo
mais ça se retient facilement si on
retient par groupes de trois où nous
avons enfin 55
le deuxième c'est 274 deuxième ses 274
débat il ya deux savoie il ya deux
savoie où 74 voix moi dans ma tête j'ai
pris deux parce que c'est le deuxième
groupe rainbow et 74
moi je pense à paris mais je sais bien
le parc donc 274 pour le mois numéro 4 5
6 donc avril méchant celui d'après c'est
263 d'accord alors là il ya un côté un
peu facile moi je trouve ces mêmes deux
que le premier oui et après ses 74 - à
chaque fois 7 ça pas si sa carte il
passe à 3 est le dernier c'est 150 353
il ya une manière il ya un email j'aime
beaucoup départementale maintenant que
tu as bien assimilé sa gelée vérifier
que j'étais pas dit connaître parce que
j'ai juste regardé vue de faire j'espère
la vidéo on apparente pour des faits
remontent rue tu vois je m'appelais les
conneries alors 2010 est né en 2016
[ __ ] j'ai eu peur j'avais tout faux
mais j'étais sur 2017
l'imbécile 2017 on en 2017 oui oui c'est
le cas mais non mais alors pas du tout
mais qu'est ce que je sais moi j'ai
adoré cette vidéo j'amènerai quand vous
voulez je te le fais sans 2018
c'est bien c'est 2018 que j'ai appris on
fait avec le code de 2018
et ça vous empêchera pas pour le faire
pour 2017 et 2019 et 2020 elle est
valable pour les velrans mais on part
sur une création via 2018 au lieu de le
faire bien d'accord la table est basée
sur le savoir le sommet du coup c'est
vraiment pété d'avoir fait ça mais 155
c'est bon de 174 n'est ce pas 263 on est
bon et 153 donc au moins je m'étais pas
gouré si les premiers lundis de 2018
c'est 155 274 bref 163 les 150 points
si je te demande quel est le premier
lundi du mois de octobre
c'est un exact donc en fait dans ta tête
entend mal tu vois un peu les paquets
par jour evra et eut trop père dedans je
prenne les paquets de moi ou le premier
lundi de juillet premier lundi de
juillet effectivement on peut en parler
à juillet donc c'est l'avant dernier
paquet le très connu puisque 7 263 c'est
leur dis de exactement fera la
gymnastique le dal et d'aller chercher
en fait quel est le jour où tombe le 1er
lundi de chaque mois oui et après tu va
utiliser ta table de cette image in
antennes et quinze jours chine le 4 le 4
mars 20 mars
oui donc le 4 0 3 oui le 4 0 3 en 2018
puisque c'est la table 2018 on va savoir
quand est-ce que ça tourne assez
facilement je suis très content et celui
de leucate lanouf est donc le premier
lundi du mois de mars c'est quand le
premier lundi du mois de mars et le 5 et
donc je serai un dimanche en famille à
mon style je serai la veille ouais donc
là là c'était sans quelques cd le 4éme
est de ta pu accéder à l'information
tout de suite et pour 2017 ça tombera
qu'en du coup un jour avant puisque là
tu es sur la table dès 2018
oh le con donc ce serait incorrect en
fait des choses à faire aucun comme vous
apprenez la tâte la table 2018
directement dites vous que quand vous
arrivez au jour vous remonter un jour en
arrière pour avoir le jour de 2017
et quand on sera en 2019 si vous voulez
chercher pour 2019 vous faites un jour
après et 2022 jours après c'est pour ça
qu'on s'en fout en fait de la table ou
est-ce qu'elle placerait ça te fait à
référence pour 2018 je veux connaître le
22 novembre 2020
le 22e le coup alors attend que les gens
donc je commence par 2018
donc déjà donc on va chercher le 11e
d'abord la 11e mois donc sert lundi cinq
exactement
voilà maintenant pour aller au 22 tu vas
chercher à additionner a rajouté 7 14 21
28 mai sans cram états d'afrique
d'accord ok ok donc j'ai vu 14 19
voilà tu va rajouter le 14 4 mai 19 donc
tu sais que le 9 et le 19 novembre 2010
suite au vote le 19 novembre de visite
est un ami oui et après tu y vas en
tâtonnant et là je vous le dis
aidez-vous des doigts
lundi 19 marne alain larue mercredi 23
jeudi 19 à weeds mer ce mardi va alors
dit jean mercredi 21 jeudi 22
donc tu sais que c'est un jeudi 2018
c'est un jeudi en 2010 7 5 mercredi
en 2019 c'est un vendredi oui mais en
2020 c'est un samedi s est ce que tu te
sens maintenant capable de le faire
ouais tu me laisse un peu de temps ouais
et en bon allez je paie dans une base de
loisirs du mois tokyo
je je je bats je vais te balancer un
petit 18 août 2010 est le gentil 18 août
2010 c'est gentil
en août on est sur du sur le fameux j'ai
déjà oublié ce qu'on sait le 263 2 263
et s'est du coup le 6 donc c'est un vin
disent tu me confirmer en rien un regard
amer 606 donc c'est le 6 août seuls que
vous pouvez toutefois confiance tu as vu
le hockey
donc lundi 6 et tu veux que j'aille au
18 mai s'il vous plaît grand plaisir
commandé 6 lundi 6 donc lundi 6 + 14 ça
ne devrait pas le faire si ça devrait
femme ses deux jours avant de frais le
vin en tout cas ça ferait un lundi 20
madiot tête tu perds mon temps maria
ouais ça devrait le faire ça je pense
légalement on peut le faire ce serait 1
5 10 18 ou 2017 on sera en famille sera
l'été sera fin est-ce que tu es sûr de
toi tu as dit que moi je te demande en
2017 il me dit que c'est un samedi en
samedi 18 août attends attends je te
confirme dis pas que j'étais péter hans
un diner d'apprenants la table de 2018
sa [ __ ] donc en fait c'est vrai pour
2018 samedi est donc ce sera vendredi
moi ça serait un bain de sang au 17 que
tu te sens capable de le faire ça temps
en temps ça jean lettre que je suis
gamin de le faire en plus surtout que
lorsqu'il m'a fait perdre du temps
notamment c'est de vous retrouver le
groupe maintient ses cinq fois que là je
pense que j'atteignais beaucoup de temps
et puis quand tu as été à l'école du
coup tu connais ta dam de cette c'est
exactement et là c'est cadeau
mais il faut juste entraîné un petit peu
la preuve est plus vous allez le faire
demain meilleur vous êtes quoi j'espère
que vous avez bien compris toutes les
étapes apprendre le code de 2017 ou 2018
une fois qu'on vous donne il a trouvé le
premier lundi du mois correspondant se
rapprocher le plus possible de la date
en rajoutant 7 14 21 ou 28 c'est à dire
un multiple de 7 et finir par
tâtonnements de trouver le jour exact si
vous avez appris le code de 2018 pour
avoir le genre de 2017
vous ferez un jour en moins de 2019 un
jour en plus et si celle-ci vous appris
comme d'habitude vous laïque et vous
vous abonner et si jamais vous avez le
malheur de pas connaître à mx m vous
pouvez cliquer le lien descriptif ou sur
le petit rond qui va paraître ici parce
qu'il reste plus que 20 secondes de
vidéo à partir de maintenant un grand
plaisir jean l'intérieur 155 274 160 353
la meilleure la malienne rokia chao
salut
[Musique]